ANZE KOPITAR, LKED OUT
>> Shane: A LOWER BODY INJURY
IN 16 GAS
GOALTENDERS.
CAL PETERSEN
BOUNCING PUCK
AND PACIORETTY SCORES! NATHAN Q
IN THE PACIFIC FOR 58 DAYS.
QU
SHEA THEODORE WIDE OPEN IN THE
KARLSSON WITH THE STEAL AT
CENTER.
TO HIS RIGHGH
NO MISTAKE, HE GETS THAT
UPSTAIRS AND ELEL
FOREHAND, HE SCORES!THE
FOREREOKING, HIS SH
PACIORETTY GETS OPEN, THE QUICK
SHOT, YOU CAN SEE IT HIT THE
POST,AT IS IT.
THE GOLDEN KNIGHTS WITH ONE
SHOT ON THATATUP AHEAD,
AGAINST MONTRC
THAT WILL BLOCK.
McNABB WITH THE HIGH BOUNCER TO
CENTER.
JANMARK WITH EIGHT
, OUT HIGH, HUTTON WI
TREVOR MOORE WORKING IT OFF FOR
ARVIDSSON.
HIS SHOT AND THAT IS TURNED
AWAY BY  A BIG
STOP WITH  2:39 TO GO.BACK , BUD
NOW, DOUGHTY BACK OUT THIRDSCOR
ADRIAN